what advice
you've taken an interesting journey
through your life uh you've you've
worked fidelity
your philosophy major uh
you're now one of the seminal minds in
the world of bitcoin and cryptocurrency
who the hell knows what the next five
ten years looks for you
if you were to give advice to somebody
uh
young today uh you know making their way
through life making a career
what would you uh what kind of advice
would you give
see the problem with advice is that in a
world where so much of success is
defined by luck
and serendipity is that the advice
givers
often don't know why they've been
successful right
and so yeah they might say you know i
was wearing a green tie
on the day of my job interview and so
you should go out and wear green ties
and so they might just get the causality
completely wrong
right i mean i'm not gonna claim that
i'm
super successful at it but um
see that's the problem is that i don't
think my journey is replicable
necessarily so
um you know who am i to to give advice
although the one thing i will say
is that the thing i did right
was to become completely obsessed
with um a domain i found really
interesting
and held promise like if i had been
really interested in like magic the
gathering i wouldn't have been able to
like
do much with that aside from build like
a killer you know card pack or whatever
um and i wasn't afraid to
you know really put myself out there um
and
you know float my thoughts online and
see how people reacted to them even if
i said stuff that was completely
erroneous or wrong all the time
the rewards to writing and just
publishing content are
immense as you know obviously it's the
most
high leverage activity i think most
young people have available to them
um and i was very lucky
and i benefited from a lot of favorable
coincidences a lot of people that took a
chance on me
um and if i had more time i would sit
here and name them
but is there something you in your
actions that
made you more open to the the benefits
of luck
sort of uh you know luck can bring you a
lot of positive and negative things
so saying you're lucky means you are
able to
ride the wave of whatever positive stuff
luck bring brought you
well that's right you have to put
yourself in a position to be lucky
and most people don't so you just have
to get as many shots on goal as possible
and of course luck is plays an
undeniable role in any career path
for sure but you do have to
make yourself available to it um
and you have to take a ton of chances
but yeah that's the problem with advice
it's just so hard to replicate it so i i
find it illegitimate most of the time
uh you heard it here kids don't listen
to anything nick just said
exactly wear a green tie to your
interviews it'll work out well
you